Wayne Johnson and Jason Statham are
Hobbs and Shah and we are the first to
take you behind the scenes let's raise
the bar you have to defy gravity
the rock shirtless and showing off his
moves Jason Statham brooding in a trench
coat and sexiest man alive
Avery's alpha turned a bad guy kicking
butt sounds like a blockbuster to us
listen I was just all in access denied
access denied access denied the first
spin-off in the fast and furious
universe takes us on a ride from London
to Samoa something the rock has always
wanted to do I'm half black and half
Sahaj I'm very proud of Who I am and the
cultures that I come from by the numbers
a staggering 183 stunt performers were
used throughout the movie Jaws fries
McLaren that'll set you back about
$400,000 the final battle scene between
good guys and bad guys took two weeks to
shoot and featured zero guns
mama where's all our guns okay readable
let's get old-school that found such joy
in these action sequences and fighting
this way just using these and biting
somebody's face and trying to break
their neck look at me
I'm Brad Superman we had to really
commit to that character and his
capabilities even though they're sort of
like do we believe that yeah he really
is black Superman
[Music]